hey guys Ryan right here I'm really
looking forward to watching this clip
it's family guy that throw down from
Fighting Irish from my understanding
this is Peter Griffin versus Liam Neeson
now I used to be a huge Family Guy fan
around season maybe seven or eight I
started losing interest I've seen up to
season ten actually but I thought the
jokes weren't just as funny as they used
to be they started feeling forced a lot
like Seth MacFarlane stuff but real fast
I do want to say people are like
complaining that I didn't really laugh
that much at the TED 2 trailer the red
band won but I didn't laugh at the Ted
trailer either and I saw it and I
[ __ ] loved it so I know that I
probably will like it at the end of the
day granted my concerns I actually
caught a million ways to die in the West
on HBO the other day for a movie I
caught on TV I thought it was pretty
funny maybe in the theaters it wouldn't
be but for a movie on TV it was worth it
so yeah I hope this is the real Liam
Neeson if not I'm sure this will still
be funny as [ __ ] does look like the
Family Guy version of Liam Neeson Oh
like taraf it sounds like him
Oh
beater you're up there now women
now if you'll excuse me I'm off to get a
free movie set haircut damn it I was
stupid to think I could beat up Liam
Neeson you guys must think I'm pathetic
are you kidding you took on the star of
Kinsey yeah and Mowgli you follow
through on your drunken ravings Wow
I guess you're right thanks guys
Kenzi J was funny because it's not one
of his action roles I've always actually
liked the Family Guy fight scenes
especially one with him in the chicken
because those fight scenes are actually
really creative and if you imagine them
being with real people it's like that
would be pretty cool they would be cool
fight scenes and I do admire how Family
Guy has always been willing to go all
out with their violence and really make
it violent and I'm pretty sure that was
the real Liam Neeson like and Liam
Neeson he's a good sport about things I
like how he's willing to parody himself
yeah I would like to see Seth MacFarlane
I know there was like a fight in Ted for
a little bit between Ted and Mark
Wahlberg but I would like to see Seth
MacFarlane like take on like an action
comedy movie I think like what the level
of creativity Family Guy has when it
comes to their action scenes and
violence that our willingness to go
all-out ridiculousness I think it could
be a pretty cool action comedy I mean I
know Seth MacFarlane isn't like one of
many people who run Family Guy now but
still like a lot of it originates from
his thoughts and he tends to work with
the same riders on his films I think it
would be a really fun time if he did an
action comedy you listening Seth anyway
guys thanks for telling me that was out
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the reel rejects and you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter the other day Jerry hacked my
Twitter [ __ ] up [ __ ]
my Twitter it was taken
Austin Black be black let's see if
you're black that would be so cool
you're not black you're a total white
kid you disappoint me
hey righty whitey okay I don't know if
you've gotten my other message but again
I wanted to tell you that you were a
true inspiration to me and my sister I
more recently gone into doing trailer
reactions with my baby sister
interesting it has went absolutely great
so far and that is all thanks to you man
your videos really inspire me and let to
awesome result all I want to say is keep
this up Ryan it's just fantastic stuff
and also try to get yourself into a
comedy movie or something man you really
deserve to get noticed no your loyal
slave sole survivors gaming however to
you man
[ __ ] competition out there well
Austin I should be flattered I should be
but just so you know I will demolish you
in subscriber count and abuse don't
think you can go toe-to-toe with righty
whitey man I will [ __ ] kill you and
if you come close to defeating me I will
literally kill you and I'll marry your
baby sister with my girlfriend's
approval but now seriously good luck to
you man